まず言えるのは このどんな人にも神通できるということはない
まあ神通というのは まあ現代風に超能力としましょう
これはどんな人にもできるわけじゃないんですが
だからといって不可能ということでもないんです
それは能力の問題で まあ一応我々論理的には四歳前に音楽を始めたら絶対音感とかなんとかとかできたりしまして
きちんとした演奏できるようになるんだと
で 十二歳とんじゃったら
まあただご苦労だけでそれほど上手にはならないんですね
ということは まあ私たちにしたっても
まあ四歳やっとなる前でもし始めたならば
やっぱり絶対音感も知っていて
もうかなりの大物になる可能性はありましたと
じゃあ今は残念ですと
指は動きませんと まあそんなもののようなことで考えてるんですね
やればできるんだと だからといってみんなにできるかなと
ですから その両方のこのなんとなくこのアンビバレンス立場を理解してください
だから瞑想すれば神通できるということはできますよと
サマーディの場合も同じことなの
やればできますよと言いながら
みんなにできるわけじゃないというんですね
ですから やっぱりこれはもう基本的な能力の問題で
まあどっちもわからないんですね
一応 まあかなり幻覚を作ること不可能だったらね
サマーディを作ることは簡単でしょうしね
変なことをイメージしたり
変なこと見えたり 思ったこと見えたりする
そういう精神的に弱いんだっていう悪口ですけどね
サマーディっていうのはまあ簡単かもしれませんし
もう徹底的にこの主観
客観性っていうのは この最初から仏教に
あの四歳の時から叩き込まれた人々にとってはサマーディなんか難しいんです
もう小さい時からもう客観性で叩き込まれたら
作れませんし 作った途端もうそれ壊しちゃうし
で そういうことなんで
例えばみんなこの外国で仏教を喋ると
そういえばあなた方の国だったらみんなすごいサマーディの達人で凄いでしょうと
あれえらい勘違いです
こういう外国より少ないんです
実際は 初めからもう客観性作ってるんだから
もうやらないというかね
作れないと 頑張っても
ですから このまあ神秘的な世界ではもう簡単にできます
で それでいいということでもどっちもないんだけどね
やっぱり物事を徹底的に集中するということだからね
そこは向こうの人々にも客観性あるんだからね
とっても簡単にやっちゃうんです
物事を集中して理解しようと思ったらね
で 誤解しにくい それから操りにくい
新興宗教に引っ張りにくい
で 引っ張る場合 一応簡単な方法っていうのは
その人々は経済的にもどん底に落ちた時
あるいはいきなり病気なんか広げて
どうしようも手上げ状態になった時は
お金やらそういうものを持っていて
ああだこうだとか ものすごい精神的なショックの時だからね
なんとか騙すことはできますけどね
それ以外はできません
一日一食でも食べてるんだったらもう無理です
他の新興宗教 カルトなんかは
で まあそういうことはこの客観性から
それはもうお釈迦様自分の教えだけで育てたらそうなっちゃうんです
いろいろもの勉強してきちゃうと
もうまた変わっちゃって困ったもんにはなります
そういうことで お釈迦様の時代ではサマーディとヴィパッサナー順番であったんだけど
仏教のみになってきたらサマーディはカットとヴィパッサナーだけということになっちゃうんです
それでヴィパッサナーでもって悟りとかなんとかとか得ても
誰もわからない 他人が
もう人はできてるんだから
だから探しても見つからない
もしかするとそういう経験ある人と一緒にじゃあ探しに行きましょうと
いう可能性もあります
[笑い]ですから もうその仏教の世界っていうのは
そういうなかなか大変な世界なんです
ものすごいオープンなんですけど
そんなこの他の人々には軽々しく判断してかみついて
ああ分かったよということはできない
つかめないというところはあります
まあとにかく神通の場合も
このあまり仏教ではね
まあやったことはないんだけど
昔はね やっぱり競争世界でしたから
まあお釈迦様も他の坊さんたちもそれなりにはやってます
お釈迦様の弟子たち みんな他の宗教から来た人々だから
まあ当然ながらそういうこともまあ実践したりはしましたし
で まあ超能力の世界なんですね
やり方っていうのはこの集中力でやるんです
まず集中力を育てる 仏教のやり方はね
それも違う 例えば現代世界でも超能力を持ってる人々がいる可能性はあります
本物かないかということわかりませんだけど
世界驚くほどのことをやると
スプーンを曲げるとかね
そういう人はいる可能性はあります
で それとまた 仏教はまたそこを客観性と科学性作っちゃうんです
仏教ではまず集中力作れと
それで第四禅定ですね
阿弥陀から言えば第五禅定まで集中力を作る
作って 今までの修行の過程でやって設定というか徹底した集中力を作る
ものすごいもの たまたまのものじゃないんです
たまげた集中力作るんです
もう瞬時に禅定に入れるぐらい
一体になれるくらい それも悟までやるんです
悟っていうのはこの喜びさえない状態
平安な状態 それから思考も全くない瞬間まで
思考全くない ただ一体という状態
そこまで作って そのエネルギー
それからその禅定から立ち上がるんです
立ち上がって普通の現象の世界に戻っちゃうんです
戻って もうほんのちょっとの前で第五禅定があったんですね
それはまあ瞬間の出来事
瞬間に立ち上がって 普通の現象の知識レベルに来る
五識のレベルに来る 来て
自分が何か希望する こうなってほしいという
例えば壁に穴があってほしいと
希望して 今度は壁に穴を作るんだということで
またさっと第五禅定に入る
第五禅定に入って 次の瞬間にその人に壁に穴があるんです
通れるんです で そういうふうな働きなんです
ですから そこでも 瞑想の種類を選ばなくちゃいけない
穴を作るということは空だ
アーカサだからそこでもって瞑想した方がいいと
アーカサという箇所でもって
そうすると簡単に穴が開けちゃいますと
穴が開けたんだからと
これ永久的にその壁に穴があるわけじゃないんです
その瞬間だけ それでそれで終わっちゃうんです
それで種類があります
自分にも穴があるんだけど
他の人にはないと だから自分が通るんだけど
他の人には通りません
他の人には壁に生えただけに見えるんです
生えて向こう側はまたいるんだと
で そこをいろいろこのチースイカー風の瞑想をしなくちゃいけないんですね
チースイカー風のつ訓練した人にはいろいろことできるんですね
なぜならば すべての物質の世界はチースイカー風なんですね
すべての物質の世界 このチースイカー風の物の
大半は心が作っているんです
だから物質的に客観的にあるのはほんのちょっとなんです
だから この宇宙はもう生命の心のエネルギーで出来上がっているので
一旦できたら宇宙の法則で動いてますけど
それでも我々の生命の心のエネルギーで動いているんです
そこはすごい簡単なことで
例えば地球はある時期は生まれたんだけど
一旦こんな物体的な生命が出来上がったら
我々の生き方によって地球の変化が変わっているでしょうね
それも心によって変化するということなんですね
我々は欲張っちゃうと
もう自然はどんどん消えていって
欲の物質が出来ると 欲の物質というのは毒なんですね
我々は怒りで巨大な怒り作っちゃうと
地球は欲の毒の物質に変わっちゃうんです
それで自分も死んでしまっちゃう
例えば今の自然破壊とか自然の問題とかは
人間の欲と怒りの結果なんですね
それで大量殺人やら大量の人を殺せるいろんな武器やらね
そういうものは原子爆弾とかね
人間の怒りの結晶なんです
だから原子爆弾というのはほんのちょっとの品物でしょ
あれはもう一一グラム一キロぐらいのもっと小さいんですけども
ウランですけど そこを爆発したら連鎖反応を起こしながらありったけのものを損してしまっちゃう
ずっと それはね 怒りの結晶で人間に怒りさえなかったならば
そんなものは現れないんです
地球になかったんです
ですから 私たち知っている世界でも
心によってものは変化するということは知っているはずなんです
そこはもっと心っていうのは
我々知っている心っていうのは思考だけだからね
思考だけじゃなくて 生きるということは心だからね
イメージということ 心だからすべてのものはやっぱり結局心によって作られる
唯識部派と違うところは
やっぱり作ったものはそこにあるんだということなんです
あるんですけど 自立していないんですね
それでもまた心によって変化させます
それは自分の心であろうが
人の心であろうが関係ない
例えば自分の心で犬小屋を作ったとする
それは犬に貸してあげたら
犬の心によって犬小屋は変化していくでしょうに
自由じゃないんですね
ある面では自由なんですね
そこで四十というか七十五パーセントぐらいの物質は心が作っているんだから
巨大な集中力生まれたら希望通りに変化しちゃうんです
でも心は瞬間だから 結果は瞬間で終わっちゃうんです
でも長い間持ちたければそれもできます
一旦変化して置いておけば
それで物質は自分で動いてますからね
その変化がそのままになることもできます
そんな話で 仏教はもう仏教はいつでも誰かを壊してるんだからね
誰を壊してるんですか？というと
この神様が作った こう作ったとかね
その考え方を壊してるんで
そんなものは人間にも可能ですよ
例えばこちらにでっかい山を作ろうと
思ったらこれ神様でない限りはできないでしょ
で 第五禅定まである人が地の瞑想して
それで第五禅定に入って
これぐらいの山を作りましょうと
形も決めて で その山が一旦作ったら山らしくあってほしいと
そしたら出来上がっちゃうんです
ですから 神様でなくてもできるんだ
それでもうどんな人から見てもそこで山があるんです
山は山らしく変化しながら
得論だという だから結局そういうことをあまりお坊さんやったわけじゃないんだけど
まあ論理的にまあ壊してるんです
だから絶対的な神ですよっていうことを壊してるでしょ
あるお坊さんがやったんだからね
けそうしたらそれその人にできますから
まあそこら辺にいる普通のお坊さんだからね
そういう価値なんですね
まあ一回あるお坊さんがね
とんでもないことやって
それでキリで禁じられたでしょうね
でっかい石の崖ですか
指 足の指で持っていって
空であっちこっちとかね
それ空に止まっておいたりしてたりして
それで大騒ぎになって
まあそういう力は禁止と使ってはいけませんということになってしまったんです
だから大胆なんです まあかえってそこまで
まあちょっとどうせ言葉だけでもね
あんなもう創造論なんかはね
インチキやということ
子供にでも説得できるんだから
そのためにあんな馬鹿げたことを何で何でやるんですかと
という意味もあります
まあちょっともうちょっと喋っただけで
創造論っていうのはもう否定できるでしょうに
それいらんと それよりはこの喋って説得する方が本物の神通力だとも言ってますね
まあとにかく地水火風の瞑想をコントロールしながら
風の瞑想で穴を作ったりする
動いたりする あの地の瞑想で空を飛んだりすることもできるし
で それから例えばいきなり遠いところに行きたくなったとすると
いろんな方法があるんです
瞑想の中で 一つは瞑想で自分が次にその場所にいるんだと思って瞑想に入る
入って瞑想から目を覚めるとその場所にいる
それで瞬時に瞬間移動なんですね
もう一つは その場所と間にある距離をなくしてもらう
で キロあるんだとする
キロの場所はこの場所と同じ場所にする
似てる隣にする 瞑想で
それで歩いていく そういうの話になって
二歩でどこまで歩いたとかねという話になりますけど
本人が別にすごいことをやったわけじゃなくて
本人は自分の隣のところに移動しただけ
で 見ている人にはその幻覚を見えませんだから驚く
驚いたりする ですから
自分にだけ見えるように神通作ることもできる
それからもう一つ 他人にも見えるように幻術を作ることもできます
それからこの自分のこの体にいっぱいコピー作る
それもできます 大体コピー作ることは結構簡単みたいですけどね
この心 我々この物体的な体っていうのは本当は心の形なんです
だから心から作られますから
この我々のこの親のせいでと言ったって意味がないんです
自分のせいなんです 自分も自分のことを知ってるんだから
小さい時の自分の顔とかね
若い時の自分の形とかね
やっぱり随分別人なんです
まあ心変わるたびにもう全部もう変わっていっちゃうんです
形が ですからこの だから体見たらね
能力と性格っていうのは体見ただけでも簡単に見えます
体っていうのはそういう
例えば子供のあれ 点数書いてあるチャートあるでしょ
それ何て言いますか 成績表ですか
まあそれだけ見たらわかるでしょうに
大体ね どんなものかというもののそんなもんで体見たらわかりますね
体っていうのは成績表みたいなもんなんです
まあですからこの心で目指して
この自分と同じ似ている体をいっぱい作ることができます
作ってもそういう体は別々に歩いて回ったりするわけじゃないんです
心一つだから この心でコントロールしなくちゃいけない
それもいろいろあります
人がもう触っても触れる可能性もあるし
あるいは触っても触れないということもあるし
他の人に見えるように作るんだったらね
まあどうせその雰囲気がすごい違うんで
とにかく空間も違うんです
だからまあ他の人々もその暗示の中に入り込んじゃうんです
すごい心のパワーだから
そういうことに成り立つだろうと思います
ですから この科学者みたいに
この大槻教授みたいに見たら見えるかどうかちょっとわからないんです
あれすっごい精神的な力だから
もうそこに参加する人々はみんなもう吸い込まれているんですね
だからその人の意のままになっちゃうんです
そういうわけで 神通力っていうのはほとんどマジシャンの出来事と同じだとまた書いて仏教で読むんです
その中でお釈迦様もよくあの
ある神通力どれぐらいあるかというと
このイッディリダンというのは今説明したものなんですね
いろいろ催し物やること
ディッバソウタンというのはこの聴覚のことなんですね
聴覚を成長させてみる
人間に聞こえないことまで聞いてみると
で パラティッチャヴィジャヤナというのは
他人の心の波動を感じてみる
あるいは人の心を読んでみるという
次にプッベーニマーサン
つまり自分の心の過去をたどってみる
それから ディッバチャックっていうのは視覚ですね
視覚を成長してみる 見る力
ですから 人間の普通の目で見えないものは見ることはできません
そこその中でこのパラチットヴィジャヤナという多心数
それから過去を見る能力
それから天眼というものは
大体作りやすくてすごいレベル高い幻術なんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の中からでも勝手に現れてくる可能性はあります
本人には本来そういう能力あるんだったら
自分が主観的に徹底的にヴィパッサナー瞑想ばっかりやってるんだけど
何の人数力も何もなくて
その時はもう勝手に付いてきたんだと
どうかの散歩に行ったら
そこら辺にいたいた子犬がついてきたんだという感じで
という風に勝手に付いてくる場合はあります
そこでその辺でもまた客観性があって
例えばここら辺で富士山ぐらい大きい山作ろうと思ったりすると
それはできるかないか
また別なもの 自分がどれぐらいパワー持ってるかっていうことにもよります
ですから 神通力持っていた人々の中でも随分差があるんですね
そのわけで目連尊者が 1番目だと言ってるんです
みんな同じ阿羅漢ですから
なんで目連尊者第一人者というと
これは心の本来持っているパワーの問題で
他の人々には一つ二つしかできないんですね
そこでディッバチャック
天眼の場合はもう一人のお坊さんがいたんですね
すごい能力があって もう別に瞑想一人しなくたって
まあそこら辺いろんなものを見えてしまうと
そうやってこの人の能力っていうのは差があります
以上 次はヴィパッサナーの世界ヴィパッサナー瞑想の方を説明しますので
30 分